A commonly held folk etymology for “doohickey”
is that it derives from the mark left on a
leaf after dew has evaporated, with said mark
essentially being akin to a the skin-blemish
definition of the word “hickey.”
Thus, lacking a commonly known word for such,
people referred to this dew mark as a “dew
hickey,” with this later evolving to “doohickey”
and eventually expanded to be used to refer
to anything that was a “thing” one couldn’t
come up with the name of.
This origin story, however, has no documented
evidence to support it and the evidence at
hand seems to easily disprove it given that
“hickey,” meaning “a skin blemish,”
didn’t pop up until a couple decades after
its inclusion in the word “doohickey.”
So where did the word “doohickey” actually
come from?
As with most words, it’s difficult to say
when exactly people started using the term,
but as for documented instances, it first
appeared in the November 12, 1914 edition
of Our Navy magazine, where it states, “We
were compelled to christen articles beyond
our ken with such names as ‘do-hickeys’,
‘gadgets’ and ‘gilguys’.”
(Incidentally, “gilguy” seems to be a
much older term than placeholder names like
doodad and doohickey, with the first documented
instance appearing in Spunyarn & Spindrift-
A Sailor Boy’s Log by Robert Brown in 1886,
where Brown also notes one of the first known
instances of “gadget”- “Then the names
of all the other things on board a ship!
I don’t know half of them yet; even the
sailors forget at times, and if the exact
name of anything they want happens to slip
from their memory, they call it a chicken⁓fixing,
or a gadjet, or a gill-guy, or a timmey-noggy,
or a wim-wom—just pro tem., you know.”)
In any event, doohickey soon spread to being
used by airman as well, with it noted in Edward
Fraser & John Gibbons’ 1925 Soldier & Sailor
Words that “doo hickey” was “an airman’s
term for small, detachable fittings.”
Within a couple decades of this, the word
was being used widely throughout America as
a placeholder name for anything one couldn’t
remember the name of.
As for how the early 20th century seamen seem
to have come up with “doohickey,” it is
thought that it probably derives from “doodad,”
which has uncertain origin, but first popped
up in documented form about a decade before
“doohickey,” with doodad meaning “a
superfluous ornament.”
The sailors thus are thought to have simply
meshed this term with “hickey,” which,
according to the 1909 edition of Webster’s
New International Dictionary meant “a device
for bending a conduit, consisting of an iron
pipe used as a handle fitted at one end with
a tee through which the conduit is passed;
(b) a small fitting used in wiring for electric
lights, a fixture piped for gas.”
By, 1913 (and likely even before) “hickey”
appears to have been given the expanded definition
of referring to any tool one couldn’t remember
the name of and later to anything at all one
needed a placeholder name for, as outlined
in a 1928 document from the Michigan Academy
of Science and Arts: “Hickie, a word applicable
to anything whose name one does not remember,
‘what’s its name’.”
As to who specifically first coined the term
“doohickey,” this has been lost to history,
but given the definitions of “doodad”
and “hickey” around the time the term
was first uttered, it seems a fairly natural
combination when referring to some device
that you can’t remember the name of in a
given moment or just one whose name is too
obscure for most people to know, requiring
a placeholder name such as doohickey, doodad,
doojigger, thingamawhatsit, watchamacallit,
thingummy, gadget, widget, gilguy, etc.
And at this point if you’re wondering where
the word “hickey” came from, this isn’t
known.
As for when it came to commonly mean a “skin
blemish,” this first started around the
late 1920s or early 1930s, mostly referring
to pimples and later expanding the definition
from there, with one early instance appearing
in the May 2, 1937 edition of Ten-Story Love
Magazine where it notes in an advertisement,
“Hickies spoil everything.
I know.
I had ’em until I began eating Fleischmann’s
yeast.”
Not long after this, “hickey” also began
being used by printers to refer to various
blemishes in engravings and
the like.